se esterilizan mediante el uso de
energías ionizantes Y estos Machos
estériles oliveros al campo y al
encontrarse con una hembra salvaje La
descendencia producida no es viable y de
esta manera mediante liberaciones
sucesivas de estos Machos logramos
reducir la población de nuestro
mosquito
[Música]
este mosquito debido a esto al aumento
de las temperaturas generales que hay en
nuestro país y en el mundo porque no
solo en nuestro país lo que hace es
poder dispersarse
más entonces cada vez se corre más al
sur su sus límites de población
antiguamente sus límites llegaban hasta
la provincia de Entre Ríos luego en el
2006 ya se encontraron muchos ejemplares
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires y en la
actualidad más o menos se cree que la
inversión es hasta Bahía blanca
[Aplausos]